[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
pour la première fois un ancien
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy a été condamné à de la prison
ferme
l'été dernier c'était un ancien premier
ministre et candidat à la présidentielle
françois fillon 50 prison dont deux ans
ferme
les décisions de justice concernant les
politiques se sont multipliés ces
dernières années les magistrats prennent
qu'il en revanche sur des élus qui leur
ont pendant longtemps maintenu la bride
sur le cou ou bien la justice est-elle
devenue indépendante et les politiques
ont un problème à être considérés comme
des justiciables comme les autres pour
en débattre nous avons invité bertrand
mathieu professeur à l'école de droit de
la sorbonne où vous co dirigé le centre
de recherche en droit constitutionnel
vous avez été membre du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature de 2011 à
en tant que personnalités extérieures
nommées par le président de l'assemblée
nationale de l'époque c'était bernard
acoyer et vous êtes l'auteur de justice
et politique la déchirure c'est paru
chez lgdj lextenso éditions bertrand
mathieu
pendant longtemps on avait l'impression
que les politiques qui ont été donnés
sous leur coupe
les juges la justice en général et
aujourd'hui on aurait l'impression que
ce serait l'un vers ce serait les juges
maintenant qu'ils tiendraient les
politiques sous leur coupe
ce que est ce que vous pensez ecoutez-la
la justice et la politique ont toujours
eu des rapports un peu difficile en
france et il est vrai pendant une longue
période que vous le dites les politiques
les responsables pudique tenez assez
largement la justice sous leur coupe où
ce genre domination mais je ne prends
pas pour plaisir véritablement que les
choses aujourd'hui s'inverse
certes les politiques n'échappe plus à
la justice et ça c'est probablement
quelque chose de positif
mais là où il ya un problème mais on y
reviendra je pense c'est lorsque les
magistrats ou les juges interfère avec
l'activité politique elle-même et
j'insiste sur ce point pour développe
rare il faut pas confondre je crois
responsabilité des hommes politiques de
droit commun devant les juges et
d'autres par intérêt
ange des juges dans l'action politique
evelyne sire-marin vous vous êtes
magistrate présidente de chambre à la
cour d'appel de versailles
ancienne présidente du syndicat de la
magistrature de 2001 à 2002 même
question est ce que aujourd'hui ce
serait les les juges qui deviendraient
les les politiques sous leur coupe
non je crois vraiment au contraire que
la justice doit gagner encore de son
indépendance peut-être on y reviendra
notamment en parlant du parquet et que
c'est tout simplement la société qui a
changé
les juges ne font qu'exercer leur
fonction régalienne à savoir d'abord
préserver des libertés individuelles ça
c'est important
et puis juger les infractions et c'est
tout simplement que on a beaucoup plus
d'exigences qu'auparavant sur le fait
qu' un homme politique est quelqu'un
absolument comme tout le monde c'est un
citoyen comme tout le monde et je crois
que c'est pour ça qu'on a peut-être
cette impression qu'il y a comme on dit
parfois un gouvernement des juges
il me semble totalement faux alors
justement est-ce que c'est notre niveau
d'exigence qui a changé mais si l'on
compare ce qui arrive à nos politiques
aujourd'hui avec les scandales
qui ont émaillé la troisième république
je pense ce scandale de panama le
scandale des fiches la sphère stavisky
l' affaire dreyfus à une époque donc où
les politiques est très très rarement
inquiété par la justice
on a l'impression que c'est pour des
peccadilles en comparaison
qu'aujourd'hui l'ancien président de la
république ancien premier ministre
ancien ministre parfois même ministre se
retrouve devant les juges et et
condamnés souvent sévèrement
vous n'avez pas cette impression event
sire-marin que au fond ce que l'on
reproche aujourd'hui à françois fillon
ou à nicolas sarkozy qui leur veut des
peines de prison ferme
c'est rien par rapport à ce dont on
était capable leurs prédécesseurs sous
la troisième république
oui alors je pense que c'est pas le
raisonnement c'est une permettre qu'il
faut savoir parce que je crois pour nos
concitoyens c'est pas rien du tout et
c'est ça qui compte c'est que on est au
21ème siècle et que voyez par exemple
monsieur fillon a été condamné à verser
plus d'un million d'euros de
dommages-intérêts pour les infractions
que le très bien judiciaire de paris a
considéré comme étant commises par lui
ce qui fait que quand vous parlez de
paix qualifie pas que le mot est tout à
fait un pop
en revanche toutes les affaires politico
financières
c'est à peu près du moment c'est à dire
que encore monsieur fillon c'est
certainement le l'enjeu financier le
moins important mais quand on voit un
certain nombre d'affaires en cours
je pense par exemple aux affaires
concernant monsieur sarkozy on verra
bien il va être jugé à partir cette
semaine dans la sphère bygmalion mais
voyez la chaire bygmalion par exemple
c'est plus de 20 millions d'euros 2
c'est ce qu'il verrait reprocher un de
dépassement de plafonds de campagne
électorale pour d'autres affaires toutes
les affaires de fraude fiscale par
exemple monsieur cahuzac etc
on est sur des sommes extrêmement
importantes également de plusieurs
millions d'euros qui aurait été
dissimulée au fisc donc quand vous dites
que c'est moins grave que les affaires
de panama j'entends à un petit bug je
vais donner la parole à bertrand mathieu
le temps qu'on on récupère evelyne
sire-marin oui il m'a écouté je crois
que en effet il ya une il ya une
véritable disproportion avec certaines
de ces affaires est pas tout
lorsque l'on parle de la sphère fillon
de la sphère sarkozy de la ferc cahuzac
de la sphère balkany je crois qu'on
mélange d affaires de nature extrêmement
différentes
la sphère cahuzac c'est la fraude
fiscale c'est du délit de droit commun
lorsque l'on énumère des millions
s'agissant du de nicolas sarkozy c'est
un problème de financement de campagne
c'est pas un problème d'enrichissement
personnel
lorsque l'on parle de la sphère fillon
c'est l'emploi d'une assistante
parlementaire
je crois qu'il y en a en effet une
disproportion alors cette disproportion
elle est dû certainement au fait que le
niveau d'exigence des citoyens est
probablement plus plus important qu'il
n'était et ça c'est en soi une bonne
chose mais il y a aussi et on y
reviendra là je pense ce sont les moyens
extraordinaires au sens propre
employé par la justice pour traiter 10
affaires qui sont importantes mais qui
ne sont pas d'une importante telle
qu'elle est plus justifiée notamment les
moyens financiers ou les moyens
techniques qui ont été engagées
notamment dans les affaires pillot ou
dans les affaires sarkozy donc je crois
qu'il ya quand même une disproportion
est vrai monsieur marc à vous avez été
coupé au juste au moment où vous allez
finir votre phrase où l'on commençait
une autre oui
ce oui ce que je voulais dire c'est que
les enjeux financiers donc pour nos
concitoyens sont très importants même si
évidemment ça peut vous sembler par
exemple dans la sphère fillon c'est un
peu plus d'un million d'euros certes
mais c'est des années de salaire qui on
aurait été perçu par madame fillon et
donc je pense que le le l'opinion
publique de nos jours n'est plus du tout
d'accord pour en quelque sorte passé
l'épongé sur ce genre d'infraction quant
aux moyens qui sont développés je suis
d'accord tout à fait avec monsieur
mathieu c'est des moyens extrêmement
important la différence entre lui et moi
c'est que lui estime que c'est tout à
fait excessif de parce que j'ai compris
mais c'est vrai que la justice
financière a changé c'est tout à fait
juste et que désormais les juges
financiers je pense que c'est une
expérience d'année d'années de justice
financière emploie les moyens de la
justice ordinaire
y compris en matière économique et
financière et on n'était pas habitués à
ça et peut-être qu'on ne le supporte pas
pour certains c'est vrai que les là la
justice ordinaire la justice pénale
ordinaire emploi comme moyens et c'est
tout à fait licite des écoutes
téléphoniques des gardes à vue des
interrogatoires successifs des
confrontations etc etc on n'était pas
habitués à ça et c'est vrai que
maintenant mes juges financiers se sont
réfléchies et ont considéré e y avait
pas de raison de séparer les méthodes
judiciaire prévue par le code de
procédure pénale entre la criminalité
organisée par exemple et les affaires
économiques et financières ont pesé non
continuer d'en donner moi je considérais
que c'est de la délinquance en col blanc
et que ces messieurs puisque je constate
que la plupart sont des messieurs
devrait être traitée différemment du
citoyen lambda mais c'est vrai que ce
n'est plus la pratique actuelle je pense
que les jeunes juges financiers
maintenant vous savez ils ont eu des
icônes à il ya eu renault vendre bec et
qui a désormais en retraite il y a eu et
val joly et un certain nombre de
magistrats c'est vrai qu'ils ont passé
le concours de la magistrature avait en
tête ces magistrats là qui sont des
figures judiciaire et pour eux en tout
cas la délinquance financière et la
délinquance environnementale j'ai
présidé pendant quelques années là une
chambre de paris qui était spécialisée
en délinquance environnementale
on voit désormais que le parquet
poursuit très systématiquement toutes
les infractions à l'environnement ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant voyez les
choses changent beaucoup il ya une
demande
je pense qu'il ya une demande citoyenne
sociale que ces infractions soient
traités comme les autres
mais alors justement est ce que nos
politiques sont des justiciables comme
les autres en principe oui
en réalité on n'en est pas sûr c'est à
dire que les moyens déployés autres
nicolas sarkozy par exemple me ne
peuvent paraître totalement exceptionnel
enfin on écoute son avocat les
conversations je peux avoir avec son
avocat en espérant trouver quelque chose
ça paraît tous les justiciables n'ont
pas droit à un tel traitement
de la même manière je prends un autre
exemple à rosas et bono mathieu weill
accès du 2 sur des affaires de droit
commun mais le cas de dominique
strauss-kahn dans l' affaire dite du
carlton de lille qui se retrouve inculpé
de de proxénétisme en bande organisée
sous prétexte qu'on le soupçonne
d'avoir eu recours à des prostituées
pour des soirées un peu spécial si tous
ceux qui ont recours aux services d'une
prostituée était inculpé de proxénétisme
en bande organisée il y aurait plus
beaucoup d'enterrement de vie de garçon
etc etc donc ça me semble est ce que
véritablement vous avez l'impression que
nos nos anciens dirigeants parce qu'il
s'agit en l'occurrence de gens qui ont
occupé de hautes fonctions
est ce qu'ils sont des justiciables
comme les autres pour les juges ou est
ce que ce sont des justiciables
on tient un peu plus à l'oeil bertrand
mathieu m'écoutais je vais prendre un
exemple pour ajouter à ce que vous avez
donné
moi je ne crois pas que c'est un certain
nombre d'hommes politiques soient
justement traités comme des justiciables
comme les autres et c'est là
véritablement le problème je prendrai la
la la l'intervention du parquet
financier le parquet financier il a été
créé à temps voire et j'ose me
prononcerai pas sur cette question
il a été créé pour traiter des affaires
particulièrement complexe et des
affaires qui avaient un champ
d'application sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
est ce que le fait de savoir si m fillon
a effectivement rempli ses fonctions
d'assistant parlementaire est un
problème financier d'une particulière
gravité ou d'une particulière difficulté
pardon est ce que le fait de savoir si
un nicolas sarkozy ou pas à chercher à
s'informer sur une affaire qu'il
concernait ou si on lui a demandé
d'intervenir auprès du ministre d'état
de monaco pour favoriser un l'un de ses
amis est ce que ce sont des affaires
d'une particulière gravité est ce que on
a on peut saisir les agendas du un
président un ancien président de la
république
probablement en violation de
dispositions de la constitution
est-ce qu'on peut écouter
les conversations entre un ancien
président de la république et l'un de
ses avocats
on voit bien qu'il y a là des moyens
extraordinaires et ses moyens
extraordinaires ça rejoint probablement
un autre aspect c est ce qui vient
d'être dit sur les priorités aujourd'hui
finalement la priorité c'est
probablement plus les délits de droit
commun ce sont les délits commis par les
hommes politiques et je dis bien nos
palais seulement les délits financiers
on l'a vu dans leur sphère strauss kahn
c'est pas un délit financier mais il y a
un certain nombre de priorités et ce qui
est grave c'est que ces priorités elles
sont légitimes ou pas mais ses priorités
elles sont fixées par les juges
eux-mêmes
les juges ont des héros on vient de le
dire les juges ont des modèles
les juges ont des combats et le problème
c'est qu'il n'appartient pas au juge
d'avoir des combats bon ou mauvais il
appartient au juge simplement de traiter
les justiciables
de la même manière le problème c'est qu
autrefois il est vrai les hommes
politiques étaient mieux traités
mais il n'y a aucune raison que mieux
traitée hier ils doivent être traités
plus mal ou différemment aujourd'hui
mais j'en revient surtout à cette
question le problème n'est pas
finalement le beau le mauvais
traitements réservés aux hommes
politiques
le problème et on l'a vu à travers ces
exemples c'est de savoir si le juge peut
intervenir dans le coeur de ce qu'est la
fonction politique
est ce qu'un juge peut allé
perquisitionner le ministère de la santé
en pleine gestion de la crise sanitaire
est ce que c'est pas là un contrôle qui
relève d'abord du politique mais il est
vrai on y reviendra que probablement le
juste comble l'absence de mécanismes de
responsabilité politique c'est une autre
question
elle va me faire ma main je crois que
bon on revient là toujours sur les
moyens exceptionnels qui seraient
déployés dans les affaires politico
financières
non je crois que tout simplement c'est
la procédure c'est à dire que
voyez dans la sphère des écoutes qui
vient d'être jugé par le tribunal
judiciaire de paris
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que bon
monsieur sarkozy c'est le tribunal qui
l'a dit un dans son dans son jugement de
256 pages cherché à récupérer des
agendas qui avaient été saisis dans une
autre afin d' affaire bettencourt dans
laquelle il a d'ailleurs bénéficié d'un
non-lieu faut quand même le dire est que
des écoutes avaient été posées dans la
sphère libyenne qui est toujours en
cours c'est une affaire très important
puisque de nombreuses personnes sont
mises en examen monsieur guillaume sur
le feu monsieur sarkozy pour des faits
graves
puisqu'on est dans des doutes
détournement de fonds publics on est
dans la corruption on est dans
l'association de malfaiteurs bon bref
l'enjeu là encore c'est un enjeu on si
les personnes sont renvoyées devant un
tribunal
entre 5 et 50 millions d'euros qui
aurait été utilisée lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2007
donc dans cette dent dans cette affaire
là j'y reviens les écoutes avait été
posée dans cette affaire extrêmement
grave affaire libyenne où je rappelle
qu'il ya quand même eu un mort
bon c'est une farine beaucoup de
tentacules et c'est pour ça que
finalement cette affaire des écoutes qui
vient d'être jugé a été jugée la au
tribunal de paris par une chambre
financière par la 32e chambre et a été
ouverte par le parquet financier parce
qu'au départ la sphère du départ était
une affaire financière
maintenant comme monsieur mathieu dit
qu' il ne trouve que c'est pas normal
qu'on écoute les conversations entre un
avocat et son client
là dessus je le rejoins en partie c'est
à dire que je trouverais normal on
encadre effectivement beaucoup mieux que
ça non pas les écoutes téléphoniques que
souvent on confond écoutes téléphoniques
les fadettes mais tout au moins le fait
d'éplucher les factures entre un avocat
les facturations détaillées entre un
avocat et son client donc ça c'est pour
pour ce point là le parquet financier
centre à 10
les affaires de monsieur autour de
monsieur sarkozy et c'est pour ça que l'
affaire des écoutes qu'une affaire assez
simple a été ouverte au parquet
financier
c'est quand même une affaire de
corruption donc c'est pas très étonnant
que ce soit ouvert ou au parquet
financier par rapport à la ce que
monsieur mathieu disait sur la priorité
des juges
alors là je m'inscris vraiment en font
parce que c'est pas mes juges qui
définissent la priorité des affaires qui
le jugent en fait les juges ne font rien
d'autre que j'ai ce qu'on leur amène
qu'on va faire c'est le parquet est une
sorte de grand centre de triage à une
sorte de grandes gares de triage c'est
ça le parquet et le parquet décide si
telle affaire est attribué à un juge
d'instruction ou pas du tout de juger
directement devant le tribunal
correctionnel ou s'il ya au contraire
une alternative aux poursuites
l affaire sera pas poursuivi devant un
tribunal mais jugés par ce qu'on appelle
la troisième voie c'est à dire un
délégué du procureur
bon etc voyez c'est les juges ne
choisisse absolument pas leur
contentieux
c'est le choix du barca c'est
l'opportunité des poursuites en france
et les juges la juge de ce qu'on leur
amène donc pour finir sur ce point
peut-être on y reviendra
on se centre là sur les affaires
financières mais quand on est sur le
terrain quand on est en juridiction
vous savez c'est rien du tout les
affaires financières ça représente c'est
très important pour les médias et pour
l'opinion publique
symboliquement mais en fait la justice
ordinaire à +2 89% des affaires pénales
se sont bons il ya 550 milles
condamnations pénales qui sont rendus
chaque année et les affaires pénales
ordinaire elles sont elles sont jugées
avec des priorités effectivement de
l'action publique
c'est les stupéfiants si les infractions
routières ça c'est ça peut vous
surprendre mais c'est ça la l'immense
majorité des affaires c'est les stups et
deux infractions routières au pénal et
puis le reste bien sûr les atteintes aux
biens les atteintes aux personnes
violences
voilà mais ces affaires financières
elles nous elle nous masque en fait la
réalité de la justice qui n'est pas du
tout qui n'est pas du tout celle là et
qui n'est pas du tout un choix des juges
mais un choix de politique pénale du
parquet à la française contre nature oui
je ne faisait que répondre à votre
affirmation sur laquelle et les juges et
est aujourd'hui particulièrement
sensibilisés aux affaires financières ou
aux affaires d'environnement sur le sur
le parquet on est on y reviendra
peut-être mais je crois que en fait il
n'ya pas que le problème des affaires
financières
pourquoi il y a cette crise quand on dit
qu'il y a une réaction d'un côté ou de
l'autre d'ailleurs pourquoi il ya cette
crise entre le politique le monde
politique et le monde judiciaire c'est
probablement parce qu'il y a très
largement une confusion des genres
à partir du moment où
des magistrats interviennent pour
apprécier des décisions politiques pour
intervenir pour prendre position dans
une élection présidentielle par exemple
il est évident qu ensuite il y a un
problème non pas d'impartialité de ces
magistrats je ne dis pas que ces
magistrats cas magistrats engagés
politiquement et nécessairement partial
ce que je dis c'est que il peut donner
le sentiment d'être partial je prendrai
vous parlez l'environnement se prendre
un exemple très simple et très théorique
pour sortir des affaires financières
je suis un pas trop paul meurt je suis
jugé par un magistrat qui est engagée
dans le dans un parti écologiste
je peux avoir le sentiment de pages avec
impartialité même si en réalité je suis
donc on a au phénomène de pénalisation
de la vie politique dont on a parlé une
forme de pénalisation de la vie
politique
on a en même temps un phénomène de
magistrats qui sont publiquement engagés
dans l'action politique et ces deux
phénomènes réuni donne l'impression que
finalement le juge sort de son terrain
naturel pour aller sur le terrain
politique
et qu'est ce qui se passe en retour
c'est que bien entendu et finalement on
peut le comprendre
à défaut de l'admettre le politique
intervient aussi pour finalement avec
les mêmes outils ou les mêmes
instruments remettre en cause ce que
fait le juge
et je crois que ce phénomène qui est
finalement des deux côtés ce phénomène
est extraordinairement malsain c'est que
la séparation des pouvoirs ne fonctionne
plus le juge se mêlent de politique et
le politique se mêle de justice et je
crois que là il faudrait essayer de
remettre un peu les choses en ordre
réponse de déve lire marc à 2 minutes 30
à peu près avant la pause
je vous laisse vous exprimer oui alors
c'est un c'est un serpent de mer cette
affaire d'impartialité des juges ça fait
très longtemps que effectivement les
juges sont syndiqués que ce soit à
l'union syndicale des magistrats et au
syndicat de la magistrature et ça c'est
quelque chose qui a toujours été tout à
fait contesté par une partie de la
classe politique
maintenant je trouve que à chaque fois
on dévie un petit peu le débat sur oui
ou non les politiques qui ont été
condamnés et je rappelle que sous la
vème république il y a deux présidents
de la république qui ont eu affaire à la
justice monsieur chirac et monsieur
sarkozy et il ya eu huit ministres au
moins j'ai essayé de faire les comptes
on est entre monsieur carignon monsieur
tapie souvenez vous monsieur cahuzac
bien sûr monsieur léotard qui vient
d'être condamné par la cour de justice
la république à deux ans avec sursis et
c'est bon on est vraiment sur des
affaires où c'est hommes politiques ont
été considérés comme étant coupable
d'infraction donc le problème c'est pas
tellement ce qu'il ya dans la tête du
juge c est ce qu ils appliquent la loi
ou pas quand il considère que par
exemple monsieur balkany a commis une
faute et fraude fiscale et de
blanchiment de fraude fiscale très
important et que effectivement il a été
condamné dans une des deux affaires à
cinq ans de prison ferme ce qui est très
important
voyez c'est on a l'impression qu'on
dévie en permanence de la question de s
que les infractions sont constituées à
les juges sont ils vraiment impartiaux
mais de toute manière oui les juges ont
des idées mais je rappelle qu'ils
appliquent quand même le code pénal et
le code de procédure pénale c'est ça qui
leur tient lieu en fait de colonne
vertébrale est pas du tout le fait
qu'ils ont leur opinion politique
maintenant si vous voulez parler de ce
qui s'est passé au syndicat de la
magistrature et que je trouve tout à
fait désastreux je le dis j'ai été
présidente du syndicat de la sphère du
mur des cons qui nous
suivra malheureusement pendant des
années oui je trouve que c'est
extrêmement dommage que de tels faits
étaient commis
le syndicat a été condamné et ça ne ça
n'arrange pas du tout l'image des juges
mais en réalité c'est un épiphénomène
totale puisque ben les magistrats
appliquent tout simplement le droit
un point c'est tout et dans les affaires
que je que je vous cite en ce moment
monsieur guérini les messieurs guérini
sont jugés à marseille c'est de ce sont
encore des affaires de corruption
et si les hommes politiques ne
commettait pas d'actes répréhensibles
on parlerait pas du gouvernement des
juges et du manque d'impartialité c'est
le font des affaires
c'est bien que au fond il ya des actes
qui sont commis qui sont des infractions
pénales tout simplement
on est d'ailleurs vendre d'appel jugeait
on fait une pause et on se retrouve
juste après l insee marre
[Musique]
une crainte de l'inflation a poussé les
investisseurs à vendre des obligations
conséquence une forte remontée des taux
sur le marché c'est plutôt un
avertissement des marchés vis-à-vis de
la banque centrale de lui dire attention
même si l'économie repart
il n'est pas question que vous changiez
politique qu'il faudra pas que les
investisseurs jeu trop longtemps parce
que c'est une grosse main comme on dit à
la réserve fédérale américaine c'est
celle qui dispose de la machine à
premier des billets de banque dans la
cave et qui a la capacité en fait de la
faire fonctionner sans aller en prison
les taux ne peuvent pas donc on va
forcer en fait les banques centrales à
continuer à faire tourner la planche à
billets comme d'habitude cette
thématique elle n'existait pas ya trois
mois elle n'existera plus dans trois
mois
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
étaient arrivés ou de ce qu'ils
pouvaient supporter il ya énormément de
problèmes en france comment se fait-il
qu'on est les impôts les plus élevés
d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés etc c'est impossible
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec bertrand
mathieu et avec evelyne sire-marin m
vous avez parlé tous les deux vous avez
fait allusion tous les deux au parquet à
l'indépendance du parquet alors on a
beaucoup parlé d'indépendance de la
justice on pourrait parler d'ailleurs de
savoir si la justice doit devenir
autonome
on a parlé de l'indépendance des juges
et elle est normalement dans la
constitution il faut que les juges
souhaitent indépendant mais le parquet
le parquet c'est différent si le parquet
devient indépendant à ce moment là c'est
lui qui est censé le pacte est
normalement celui qui incarne la
collectivité qui incarnent l'intérêt
général et si le parc est indépendant à
ce moment là le parquet va faire la
politique que judiciaire la politique
pénale de la france à la place du
gouvernement alors est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter un parquet indépendant
bertrand mathieu est ce que vous
permettez de revenir danse des mots sur
ce qui peut être dit avant jc
répondant même si un marin très très
rapidement d'abord sur l'application du
droit pénal bien entendu le juge
applique le droit pénal mais on sait
bien qu'il ya une marge d'interprétation
extrêmement large
je prendrais dans la sphère sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy et condamné à juste
titre ou à tort je n'en sais rien sur la
base d'un soupçon et non pas sur la base
d'une preuve sur la base d'une
présomption sur le les à condamnation
des hommes politiques bien évidemment
qui est légitime de condamner les hommes
politiques pour des affaires de droit
commun ce que je sous l'eau je parle
seulement c'est les moyens qui sont
utilisés ou les interférences dans
l'action politique
et quant à l'impartialité je ne mettais
pas en cause particulièrement la sphère
du mur des conquêtes une affaire
regrettable ne peut pas juger un
syndicat qui à travers cette affaire
ce que je mets beaucoup plus pour moi ce
qui me paraît beaucoup plus grave
c'est par exemple qu'un syndicat et pris
position lors d'une élection
présidentielle
et comment dans l'opinion on ne peut pas
avoir un soupçon
lorsqu'un ancien président de la
république est condamné à la suite d'une
procédure qui utilisent des moyens
légaux mais extraordinaire sur la base
de soupçons et que les syndicats
d'ailleurs les deux syndicats de
magistrats ont très largement pris parti
politiquement contre lui donc là je
crois qu'il ya un problème dans dans
l'opinion mais je voulais revenir sur la
question vous posiez sur le parquet ça
je crois que c'est une des questions
clés mais vous l'avez formulée de
manière assez juste fo considère que la
justice est un pouvoir totalement
autonome des deux autres et dans ce cas
là il faut un parquet qui finalement
décide librement un parc et autonome le
problème soit on considère qu'on reste
dans notre système démocratique et dans
ce cas là il y a un gouvernement qui
détermine la politique pénale la
politique de la nation et notamment la
politique pénale et qui en est
responsable devant le parlement
et dans ce cas il est normal que le
parquet soit soumis à l'autorité du
gouvernement et d'autre part le parquet
a en charge en effet de défendre
l'intérêt général tel qu'il est défini
par la majorité politique
donc je ne crois pas ray park est
totalement indépendant même si les
magistrats qui forment le parquet
doivent bénéficier une certaine
indépendance dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions evelyne sire-marin peut-être
il nécessaire de rappeler la différence
entre le parquet les juges magistrats du
siège les maillots voilà peut être un
petit point rapide pour que tout le
monde d'accord sur le parc est
effectivement mais un monsieur mathieu
le sait largement aussi bien que moi
puisqu'il a été membre du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
le parquet n'est pas un magistrat
indépendant
d'abord pour la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui l'a jugé un
certain nombre de fois et
jugé que ce n'était pas une autorité
judiciaire que le parquet en france le
procureur
en réalité est nommé par le garde des
sceaux avec un simple avis consultatif
du conseil supérieur de la magistrature
et ça c'est une réforme depuis très très
longtemps que d'ailleurs beaucoup de
politiques ont opposé y compris je crois
monsieur macro mais monsieur hollande
aussi madame guigou avait essayé de le
faire mais monsieur chirac n'avait pas
réuni le congrès de façon à ce que les
procureurs ne soit désormais plus nommé
par le garde des sceaux mais nommés sur
avis conforme du conseil supérieur du
trader ça vous semble peut-être de la
cuisine mais c'est très important la
nomination et la carrière des procureurs
si elle dépend du garde des sceaux donc
de l'exécutif
à ce moment là ça pose infections ce
problème d'indépendance alors il ya des
il ya deux choses à à distinguer dans la
justice le parquet qui effectivement pas
reçoit en quelque sorte des demandes
d'informations on l'a vu dans un certain
nombre d'affaires cet été et faire
remonter des informations au garde des
sceaux
le parquet qui est donc entre guillemets
nommé plus ou moins afin parle par le
garde des sceaux
et puis les juges qui sont les juges
indépendants et les juges indépendants
eux sont nommés par le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature avec un avis conforme
de ce conseil qui est composé à la fois
de magistrats et puis de personnes de la
société civile
alors la question qui se pose c'est en
fait une double question est ce que en
france il est bon que il y ait un corps
unique de magistrats du siège comme on
dit les juges indépendants et le parquet
dont c'est le système qui est adoptée en
france en belgique en italie mais il ya
d'autres pays d'europe qui n'ont pas du
tout notre système et ça marche
finalement pas mal du tout je pense à
l'allemagne je pense au portugal je
parle pendant sa litanie
ou pardon par l'italie et à l'espagne
donc dans ces pays si vous voulez vous
avez deux corps séparés
c'est à dire d'une part les magistrats
du parquet d'autre part les magistrats
du siège qui ont des carrières séparées
on ne passe pas de l'un à l'autre comme
en france alors ça c'est une question
est la deuxième et enfin la seconde
question c'est la question de
l'indépendance la question
d'indépendance elle est très délicat
parce que elle dépend aussi si vous
voulez des circonstances quand tout va
bien en démocratie c'est pas très gênant
ont finalement d'avoir un parquet qui ne
soit pas indépendant mais là en ce
moment je trouve qu'il ya quand même des
difficultés quand on voit que dans la
sphère des écoutes par exemple de
monsieur sarkozy
on voit que garde des sceaux qui est
très proche d'un des prévenus de
l'avocat monsieur herzog a ouvert une
enquête disciplinaire contre les
magistrats du parquet financier qui
voulait savoir comment ça se faisait que
les écoutes n'avait plus rien donné à
partir d'un certain moment parce que
monsieur sarkozy avait compris qu'il est
écouté
voyez là quand on a une intervention du
pouvoir politique à un conflit d'intérêt
entre le garde des sceaux
et puis une affaire judiciaire on voit
que c'est un problème que le parquet ne
soit pas indépendant mais ça pose bon ou
d'autres problèmes c'est une question
globale on peut pas aborder
l'indépendance du parquet tout seul
c'est à dire par exemple on prend le
système italien qui a des défauts certes
mais en italie il n'y a pas de garde à
vue y a pas de juge d'instruction
donc si on a un parquet indépendant il
faut se décider en france à mon avis à
supprimer le juge d'instruction auquel
par ailleurs les français sont quand
même très attachés parce qu'il voit bien
dans un certain nombre d'affaires c'est
grâce au juge d'instruction les choses
avancent magistrat indépendant
voyez c'est ainsi c'est un problème
global et c'est vrai qu'en france on a
une conception du parquet qui n'est pas
indépendant ce qu elle nous vient de la
révolution française on estime
effectivement que le pouvoir politique
doit à pouvoir faire descendre ses
instructions sa volonté à travers
les procureurs mais on peut tout à fait
si on conçoit un parquet indépendant à
ce moment là à dire on va le parquet
applique la loi applique tout simplement
le code pénal le code de procédure
pénale c'est vrai avec le problème que
ça pose parce qu'il faut toujours à être
assez circonstancié sur ces questions le
problème que ça posera c'est que chaque
procureur pourra nommer enfin pour al
pourra décider un peu de sa politique
pénale
et ça c'est un problème pour l'unité de
la politique pénale sur tout le
territoire donc c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué mais je pense que
déjà si les corps étaient séparés siège
est parfait comme ça se passe dans
d'autres pays
je pense qu'on éviterait ce pas mal
d'écueils déjà en france c'est la
volonté de d'eric dupond-moretti non je
me trompe de vouloir les sépare est
justement alors il l'a dit un dansant il
a fait un très beau discours un
d'investiture maintenant dans le
discours d'investiture il y avait
notamment ça c'est pas du tout ce qui
est prévu dans sa réforme de la justice
enfin tel qu'il l'a annoncé dans la
presse parce qu'à une réforme annoncée
dans un interview
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait sérieux
et suffisant pour voir ce qu'il ya
dedans mais ça pour l'instant il a tout
à fait abandonné cette idée il ya
d'autres idées intéressantes dans sa
réforme d'autres beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins intéressant par notamment au
niveau de l'exécution des peines bande
supprimer les peines automatiques ça
c'est un vrai problème pour les visons
surtout qu'elles sont pleines mais il
l'a là dans la réforme qu'il prévoit à
partir du mois d'avril de présenter au
conseil des ministres
il n'est pas du tout question ni de
l'indépendance du parquet ni de la
séparation du corps il ya d'autres
choses dedans notamment bombard le
respect du secret professionnel des
avocats en encadrant ces fameuses
facturations détaillées et en les ans
les en les limitant uniquement au cas où
l'avocat est vraiment déjà soupçonné
d'être coupable de quelque chose d'autre
point
de cette réforme qui me semble pas du
tout une intéressante sur l' enquête
préliminaire de limiter à deux ans
maximum trois ans l'enquêté préliminaire
parce que c'est vrai qu'il faut quand
même
c'est une enquête qui est purement
policière un sous l'égide d'un parc est
pas indépendant c'est quand même un
problème enquête préliminaire et sa
durée en france sa porte vraiment
atteinte aux droits de la défense
il ya des choses intéressantes tout
n'est pas intéressant loin de là mais le
parquet à chaque fois tous les
gouvernements se sont cassé les dents
sur la question de l'indépendance du
parquet et de la réforme du parquet
bertrand mathieu oui moi je ne suis pas
en désaccord avec l'ensemble des propos
de madame st marin je dirais simplement
que l'un des problèmes
l'un des problèmes du parquet c'est en
effet qu'elle est quel est son rôle
on a en fait deux grands systèmes on a
un système quel système anglo saxon où
les enquêtes à charge sont conduites par
des fonctionnaires
c'est le cas par exemple aux états unis
et que finalement il reste aux à la
personne poursuivie avec son avocat
d'assurer la défense
notre système est est différent et je
crois que probablement il est plus il
est plus respectueux des libertés que
l'on est en france une garde à vue
qu'ils soient placés sous le contrôle
d'un magistrat fut-il pas totalement
indépendante et le procureur plutôt que
d'être placée uniquement sur des
autorités de police ou sous le contrôle
d'un fonctionnaire donc je crois que là
qu'est ce que c'est finalement le
parquet le parquet au le procureur c'est
l'interface entre le pouvoir politique
et le pouvoir judiciaire il appartient
aux pouvoirs judiciaires à l'autorité
judiciaire
mais il est l'interface entre les deux
on ne peut pas avoir dans un système de
séparation des pouvoirs des pouvoirs
qu'il soit totalement autonome l'un par
rapport à l'autre
il faut toujours que des mécanismes de
contrôle de poids et contrepoids et
j'allais dire
quand montesquieu dit que tous pouvoirs
sont limités est un pouvoir dangereux
le pouvoir de la justice qui serait pas
limitée sera aussi un pouvoir dangereux
et donc il faut une possibilité
d'intervention du pouvoir politique
je reprendrai la faire on a en a cité la
sphère du garde des sceaux
concernant les poursuites disciplinaires
contre eux ou tout au moins des dvd et
des eaux des poursuites administratives
dans un premier temps contre un certain
nombre de magistrats
je crois que ce qui était intéressant
dans cette affaire c'est que bien
entendu on peut avoir un problème de
conflit d'intérêts mais on se trouve
dans une situation qui montre bien le
blocage le garde des sceaux engage des
poursuites administratives contre les
magistrats et d'un autre côté des
magistrats engage une information
judiciaire contre le garde des sceaux ya
véritablement un problème là quelle que
soit la situation
on ne peut pas considérer que parce que
le garde des sceaux et talent un ancien
avocat il se trouverait pieds et poings
liés dans les procédures qui pourraient
engager contre un certain nombre de
magistrats alors sous toutes les nuances
du la situation du parquet je suis assez
d'accord mais la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme je crois qu'elle a
assez mal compris ce qu'était le parquet
parce que la française parce qu'elle dit
non seulement qu'il n'est pas
indépendant
mais elle dit aussi que c'est une partie
au procès or le procureur n'est pas une
partie au procès il est là pour défendre
les intérêts de la société spa lé
défenseur des victimes
si le défenseur des intérêts de la
société et je crois mais peut-être ça
n'oublie serait sur un autre débat c'est
que la sphère la sphère dupond-moretti 6
pu l'appeler ainsi qu'on appelle
toujours l'un à faire par les noms des
protagonistes la sphère dupond-moretti
elle pose un problème qui est celui
des magistrats du siège comme tuer des
magistrats du parquet c'est le problème
de la responsabilité et je crois que
s'agissant des uns et des autres on a un
problème qui est celui de responsabilité
puisque à partir du moment où leur
compétence leur puissance 7 ans il est
bien entendu que leurs responsabilités
doit aussi obéir à des règles à des
règles plus exigeantes et je crois que
de ce point de vue là la réflexion qu'a
engagé le président de la république sur
la question de la responsabilité des
magistrats est une question très
importante dans le cese qui nous
rassemblent aujourd'hui sur les rapports
justice et politique c'est une question
qui est extrêmement complexe parce que
soit on ne touche pas du tout à
l'activité juridictionnelle du magistrat
et dans ce cas là la responsabilité
d'actes de d'épée dans l'eau
soit on va trop profond dans le contrôle
de l'activité juridictionnelle du
magistrat et dans ce cas là on met en
cause risquent de mettre en cause son
activité et je vois que là il ya une
ligne approuvé une réflexion engagée
mais cette réflexion engagée peut-être
qu'elle paraître un secondaire en
réalité elle est au coeur de la
confiance que les justiciables peuvent
avoir dans les magistrats moi j'ai
participé au dispositif qui permettait
aux citoyens d'engager la responsabilité
des magistrats
ça fonctionne pas ça fonctionne pas
d'ailleurs pour des raisons de procédure
ça ne fonctionne pas parce que les
justiciables ont du mal à s'approprier
cette question mais ça ne fonctionne pas
et il ya une véritable
ya une véritable nécessité de trouver
ces mécanismes d'engagement de la
responsabilité des magistrats mais aussi
et je sais que je serai en désaccord
profond avec madame c'est marine mais
probablement qu'on trouvait peut-être
des points d'équilibré
c'est que ça doit toucher aussi
l'activité jurisprudence activités
juridictionnelles
lorsque par exemple un magistrat fait
des fautes caractérisées par exemple
lorsqu'il fait des erreurs graves de
procédure répétée
lorsque par exemple il ne se trouve sur
le nez fait eux mêmes
je crois que là il ya il ya une
procédure à prouver une réflexion
engagée et je crois qu'il faudrait
mettre toutes les bonnes volontés
possible à la fois celle d'aider des
syndicats de magistrats
et encore une fois sur une petite
incidence mais ça sera la dernière je ne
suis absolument pas opposé aux syndicats
de magistrats est squatté répondre à une
nécessité mais le rôle des syndicats de
magistrats c'est de défendre des
intérêts de des magistrats est de
s'intéresser aussi à l'organisation de
la justice
c'est sûrement pas de prendre position
sur des questions politiques sur
l'immigration sur l'élection d'un
président de la république etc
mais cette petite parenthèse fini je
crois qu'il y aurait intérêt à débattre
avec les syndicats de magistrats de
cette question là de manière très divers
ses 25 marins j'imagine que vous voulez
répondre à une dernière question que
j'aimerais poser à tous les deux c'est
la responsabilité aussi les politiques
dans tout ça est ce que font les
politiques n'est ce pas démissionner
depuis un certain nombre d'années et
n'ont pas fait cadeau au juge en général
d'énormément de pouvoir tout simplement
parce que est une des raisons de leur
perte d'influencé d'ailleurs ou
politique parce qu'ils sont défaussés
quand même ils ont démissionné sur plein
de sujets mais je vous laisse répondre
parce que j'imagine que vous ne répondra
pas que oui en ce qui concerne montrait
très rapidement à une petite précision
quand même sur les questions de monsieur
dupont moretti
il a quand même ça s'est jamais vu je
crois sous la vème république il a quand
même été dessaisi
i 2 c de ses pouvoirs concernant la
discipline des magistrats pour les
affaires qu'il avait à traiter comme
avocat dans son cabinet en fait c'est
pour ces affaires là c'est pas parce
qu'il était avocat avant ça c'est pas du
tout un problème
moi je trouve c'est une très bonne chose
a qu'un avocat soit garde des sceaux ou
qu'une avocate comme ça a été le cas
dernièrement soit nommé à la direction
de l'école de la magistrature
écoutez c'est très bien on est des
juristes je pense que il ya des échanges
extrêmement fructueux qui peuvent se
faire à ce niveau là non le problème de
monsieur dupont moretti c'est que il a
exercé son action disciplinaire comme
garde des sceaux contre des magistrats
qui du parquet qui avait eu de vrai dans
des affaires où il était l'avocat d'une
des parties il ya aussi le juge levraud
à monaco qui lui avait bons coups des
plus puisque ce juge levron avait fait
une perquisition dans une affaire où
monsieur dupont moretti et l avocat de
la personne perquisitionnée et il a une
procédure disciplinaire ce magistrat bon
c'est de ça qu'il a été dessaisie je
crois que c'est une bonne chose qu'il a
été dessaisie tita parce que là il y
avait un vrai conflit d'intérêts sur la
question de l'indépendance
oui c'est vrai les juges effectivement
peuvent apparaître peut-être parfois
comme très peu compétent dans certains
jugements on peut on peut penser c'est
légitime de penser ça quand on a de
toute façon vous savez nous on fait un
métier où personne n'a jamais content ça
surtout comme juge pénal
de toute façon le prévenu n'est jamais
content d'être condamnée et la partie
civile n'est jamais contente non plus
parce que les dommages intérêts ne sont
jamais assez important donc non on fait
un métier comme ça et mais c'est vrai
qu'on est on doit être très responsable
de ce qu'on fait je crois que c'est le
cas un rendre la justice avec les mains
tremblantes avait dit monsieur canivet
quand il était premier président de la
cour de cassation
mais il ya un pour le pur pour ces
problèmes-là d'abord il ya un double
degré de juridiction c'est-à-dire la
cour d'appel dans les affaires dont on
parle est par exemple tout à l'heure un
notaire
la sphère barque balkany la sphère
cahuzac
on pense ce qu'on veut mais la cour
d'appel a complètement confirmée
les juges du premier ressort et puis il
ya vraiment un gros problème qui n'est
pas du tout théorique c'est que vous
savez on est indépendant quand on a un
peu les moyens d'exercer son métier et
je pense que c'est comme les
journalistes c'est à dire que quand on a
trop de travail quand on est débordé
quand on n'a pas de moyens là c'est
aussi ça la question de l'indépendance
c'est pas uniquement la procédure
disciplinaire le concessionnaire la
magistrature alors vous savez que la
justice française c'est pas qu'elle est
pauvre c'est qu'elle est c'est une
clocharde mais plus ni moins 1 c'est
vraiment une justice qui manque
totalement de moyens même s'il ya des
efforts qui sont faits mais on est
vraiment au niveau des moyens on manque
énormément de magistrats vous savez
quand un juge des enfants prononce une
mesure éducative pour aider un mineur en
danger
elle est prise en compte parfois un an à
18 mois après vous parle des bandes on
parle des violences urbaines etc
mais c'est absolument terrible l'état de
la justice des mineurs
moi en ce moment je suis juge sociale à
la cour d'appel de versailles
quelqu'un qui est licencié il est jugé
au conseil des prud'hommes deux à trois
ans après et à la cour d'appel à peu
près quatre cinq ans après et c'est dans
toutes les cours d'appel comme ça il ya
vraiment comme le dit la fontana
puissant souverain qu'un souverain qui
meurent de faim voilà c'est tout est dit
je blogue la justice dans ce qui les
moyens oui
bertrand mathieu oui sur les moyens je
suis assez d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit et je crois que c'est une une
analyse qui est assez consensuel je
dirais sur le problème
je crois qu'il faut se méfier finalement
de dire quand on dit le juge applique la
procédure le juge applique le droit
pénal
certes mais le problème c'est qu'il y a
une marge de manoeuvre considérable
notamment emmène en matière pénale dans
ce que peut faire le juge et quand on
dit que finalement on dit souvent si il
y à un juge au chili à une juridiction
dans laquelle il ya un problème c'est
pas très grave parce que finalement il
ya des recours recours en appel ou en
cassation
c'est vrai mais il faut pas oublier
quand même la situation d'un justiciable
qui pourrait être du fait d'un jugement
mal rendu ça peut arriver ça arrive dans
toutes les professions qui à la suite
d'un jugement man rendu va se prouver
atteint soit dans sa vie personnelle
soit dans sa vie sociale soit dans sa
situation financière et qui restera
pendant plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années parce qu'en effet la justice est
lente vos fautes de moyens va se
retrouver dans une situation à laquelle
à laquelle il ne sera jamais faits
réparation finalement donc je crois
qu'on ne peut pas tout attendre de la
procédure des recours et chacun devrait
revenir peut-être sur la question pour
pour avancer dans dans ce débat sur la
question que vous posiez frédéric taddeï
sur la faute des politiques
je crois que oui il ya une faute des
politiques à plusieurs degrés par
exemple prendrait des exemples très très
variés par exemple ne reste que deux
minutes bertrand mathieu je dirais les
réseaux profonde c'est qu'il n'y a plus
de responsabilités politiques
à partir du moment où rien sa vie était
politique
si devant les juges que s'exerce la
responsabilité il n'y a plus de
responsabilité du gouvernement devant le
parlement il n'y a plus de
responsabilités des élus devant le
peuple
et finalement ça déséquilibre le système
parce que c'est le juge qui prend la
place et puis d'autre part pour des
raisons x y ou z
les citoyens n'ont plus confiance dans
le politique et comme ils n'ont plus
fait en faisant la politique il se
tourne vers le juge en fait voulu faire
remplir une fonction qui n'est
probablement pas celle pour laquelle il
est fait mais dans ce cas là ce sont
probablement les dérives du politique
qui conduisent la nature a horreur du
vide qui occupent conduit la justice à
occuper une place qui n'est pas
nécessairement la sienne une réponse
devient ferma en 30 secondes en 30
secondes je pense que notre justice a
connu une évolution tout à fait néfaste
de la collégialité c'est à dire trois
juges qui est quand même là aussi c'est
montesquieu à un juge arrête le pouvoir
d'un autre jeu c'est à dire que vous
voyez les les audiences il ya trois
magistrats par exemple en
correctionnelle ou à la cour d'assises y
en a plus et ça c'est une énorme
garantie est de plus en plus
malheureusement la justice est rendue en
juge unique et c'est vrai j'entends tout
à fait quand monsieur mathieu dit oui
s'il ya une mauvaise décision qui est
rendue eh bien ce sont les gens qui en
subissent les conséquences
et je pense qu'il faudrait revenir
vraiment à plus de collégialité parce
que on débat avec la collégialité et je
peux vous dire que là les décisions
elles sont encadrées en fait
juridiquement quand on est 3 vous
remercie oui un mot il faudrait que les
juges uniques soit des juges
expérimentés et que les juges en
collégialité soit de jeunes juges tout
au moins parmi cette collégialité je
crois qu'il faudrait dans ce cas la
revoir complètement l'organisation
juridictionnelle
merci tous les deux d'avoir participé à
ce débat merci de nous avoir suivi et on
se retrouve au prochain numéro
[Musique]